[Music]
everyone is going absolutely insane I'm
not just talking about the obviously
insane people like Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump but also the regular people
in your life like your co-worker your
friend and your cousin we're all going
completely bonkers over this freaking
election people are losing friends
blocking family members on social media
and screaming at perfect strangers I'd
say we've hit rock bottom but with 60
days until the election I don't even
think we're halfway there yet maybe the
worst part about this election Fiasco is
that nobody knows who to trust anymore
our mainstream media has failed us by
cozying up to the very people they were
supposed to be watching there's an
unholy alliance between members of the
media and politicians to never really
accomplish much of anything if you're in
the media the less you analyze and the
less you question the higher you'll
climb if you're a politician the more
you pander and the less you tell the
truth the more votes you'll get the Fox
isn't just guarding the henhouse but he
set up shop in there and he's selling
the eggs to the highest bidder of course
it's not just mainstream media that's
the problem here online media has in
many cases gone from refreshing and
necessary to discredited and
untrustworthy when everyone is reporting
on the news nobody is when everyone has
a website nobody does and when anyone
with money can fund another operation
that looks like a place to journalism
when it's really just a front for
propaganda well then we're officially in
trouble people often ask me who in the
news I trust and at this point I'm
really not sure who to say there's so
much noise out there coming at us from
so many different directions that
pilfering some truth out of the void is
almost impossible it doesn't have to be
like this
nor was it always like this but
somewhere along the way we got
distracted by scandals and drama instead
of focusing on issues and reality plenty
of good people have tried to warn us and
tried to correct course but we didn't
heed their warning and now we're left
with the system that is chugging along
despair
viii itself not because it's working as
it was intended to I'm not one of the
people who want to burn down the system
at all costs but if right now at this
very moment we can't recognize that is
something that something is very wrong
then is there any chance we'll ever wake
up all that said it's still pretty great
here in the US of A people all over the
world still want to come here to make a
better life for themselves and you don't
see many Americans leaving here to go
make a better life elsewhere despite how
nauseating this election is look how
engaged citizens are this country is
still a melting pot of people from every
corner of the globe who came here to
make a better life for themselves and
their children yes we have our problems
but most of the world would gladly trade
their problems with ours in the midst of
all this craziness one of the most
important things any of us can do is
figure out what we stand for as the old
adage says if you don't stand for
something you'll fall for anything
and maybe that more than anything else
explains our current political situation
nobody in government has really stood
for much of anything for the past few
years and because of that the masses
have now elected two of the least
favorable candidates in American history
Washington and Lincoln they are not all
the way back in 1999 a former pro
wrestler and movie star named Jesse
Ventura ran perhaps the most unlikely
campaign in American history as a member
of the Reform Party he ran against the
Democrats the Republicans and the system
as a whole despite all odds Ventura won
the election and became possibly the
biggest outsider ever elected to be
governor in our entire country's history
though he left the Reform Party after
just a year in office Ventura had a
pretty successful run as governor he
lowered income tax oversaw several
successful infrastructure projects and
perhaps most importantly got new people
especially young people involved in
politics unfortunately the grind in the
system did eventually wear him down and
he didn't run for reelection in 2003
since leaving office Ventura has been
involved in politics
teaching writing and hosting a couple TV
shows most recently on my old home a
tour a TV he revels in being politically
incorrect he calls out both sides and he
isn't afraid to go down the conspiracy
rabbit hole well I don't agree with
everything he says I love having voices
like his out there keeping the people in
power in check and challenging the
establishment narrative so my call to
you this week regardless of whether you
agree or disagree with Jesse Ventura is
to be a little more like him in one
regard don't be afraid to say what you
think and share your ideas in the public
square we need more people like you to
be outspoken now more than ever so we
don't only hear from the crazy people
it's not about whether you're right or
wrong it's about whether you're willing
to stand up and be counted
otherwise we're just gonna let the
inmates run the asylum my guest this
week is a former professional wrestler
movie star television host author and oh
yeah
former governor of Minnesota governor
Jesse Ventura welcome to the Rubin
report great to be on the Rubin report
it's far too long since we talked to
each other it's been a while now first
off you we've done this a couple times
as I've bounced around from networks and
you've bounced around but first off are
you off the grid right this moment no
I'm right this moment in the heart of
Manhattan so that's hardly off the grid
no I'm in the middle of a book tour and
I had to fly to New York and I'll spend
four days out here doing the the massive
publicity stuff that you do with every
book and then I'll go back to Minnesota
and then I've just signed a new contract
with Russian television America so I'll
be getting ready to do 32 shows for them
we'll crank out eight of them and then
I'll go to Mexico and then at some point
I'll do eight more and we haven't
figured out exactly when where and how
yet but it won't be off the grid because
now that I work for Russia they don't
have the political pull and the
paperwork to do the show from Mexico so
it can't be off the grid any
I'll be doing it from Minnesota which of
course is on the grid right now what
kind of red-blooded American that I know
you are could work for Russia well
that's a question I'm gonna ask in my
first show I want to know what Russia's
done now to make us hate them so bad I
mean they were our allies in World War
two they fought side by side with us in
fact they took the brunt of World War
two against the Nazis and yet before the
war was even over there our enemy while
I realized why finally I read a book on
Allen Dulles if you know who he was
former head of the CIA yeah well think
about in a minute Wall Street ran our
country back then what is Wall Street's
biggest fear socialism
well they would Wall Street would rather
get in with fascists and Nazis than they
would socialists and that's how I
determined why before the war was even
over almost Allies to my father were now
our enemy and so I want to know now that
they're not socialists anymore I was
there in December they are full-blown
capitalists in fact they've embraced
capitalism so strongly in Moscow stores
every stores open 24 hours a day Wow now
that's embracing competition and
capitalism so now that they're
capitalists why do we still want a war
with them wait as a joke I said wait a
minute
because they're capitalists and they're
even white so they've got everything
going for them they got everything going
for them you know and and I'm and I
would like an answer as to why we
continue to build up to another Cold War
the only answer I can come up with is
feeding the industrial war complex yeah
isn't that ultimately what so many of
our decisions ultimately come down to
that there's just so much money out
there that we always need a new enemy
and not to say look Putin's doing some
strange stuff in Ukraine obviously in
some other places but that we're always
looking for another enemy just because
that is
the money machine yeah it we we are now
a culture of war I mean take a look on
TV you see Arnold Schwarzenegger doing
those commercials for the video game
right we glorify war we've decided that
people that go to war our heroes and
need to be glorified well for my first
question is how is killing someone else
a hero and and it brings up a great
point that I did on off-the-grid I raise
the question who's more powerful God or
government well clearly government is
because God says thou shalt not kill
there's no asterisk there it's simple
thou shalt not kill right yes
yet if you kill for governments behalf
or at the behest of government not only
can you kill you're a hero if you do it
if you kill for government you're a hero
well that clearly says government
doesn't listen to God and God doesn't
penalize government for it so
governments clearly more powerful than
God yeah and it seems that God has a
bunch of believers who are all mixed up
because a lot of people are killing in
the name of God too even if he says
don't do it exactly same the good point
same thing but yet you're made a hero if
you kill at behest of government shoot
they got holidays for you they'll pay
the National Football League to honor
you that's that one yeah that swept
under the rug quick when they found out
in the defense bill our tax dollars were
paying the billionaire owners of the NFL
to honor the veterans what do you make
of that what's going on now with
Kaepernick and this instant you know
kneeling for the National first of all
that's a slap in the face to me as a
veteran mm-hmm
that these billionaire football owners
have to get paid to honor me now
Kaepernick I support him a hundred
percent you don't have to agree with
what he's protesting if you do or don't
but you need to support his right to do
it because if we take away Colin
right to not stand for the flag one
thing people need to remember clearly
you can't mandate patriotism
you can't force patriotism the last
people who force patriotism was 1930s
Germany they were called Nazis that was
forced patriotism patriotism has earned
a government earns your patriotism a
government can't mandate or make you be
patriotic they have to earn it and colin
kaepernick whether you agree with what
he's doing or not should be supported in
his right to protest that's what makes
our country great well you saw the
second time he did it who was standing
next to him that green beret that wrote
an op-ed piece in his favor stating he
didn't agree with him but he supported
his right to do it and that's what he
defended our country to have that right
and all you noticed the people who
protest the most are the ones that were
never in the military right does that
mad in you when you see that people
simply don't understand the two-way
street that freedom really is because he
has the freedom to do it in that he
doesn't have to stand for it and then
other people have the freedom to mock
him so no one's saying they don't have
the freedom but that people don't
understand that sort of social contract
that we have well it was like when I was
governor I tried to tell people look
with freedom comes to the freedom to be
stupid
it's a yin and a yang that if you're
going to accept freedom humans are gonna
make stupid decisions you have to accept
that as part of freedom that the freedom
and like I told my people you can't
legislate stupidity you can't make every
time a person does something stupid you
can't make it against the law right like
to me the most asinine law in America
it's against the law to commit suicide
well if the person successful how do you
prosecute up right and if he's not
you're gonna put him in jail because he
tried to kill him
self yeah that leads to my book
marijuana manifesto how how can you put
people in jail for committing a crime
against themselves now it might be
stupid to use drugs maybe maybe not
depending on who you are but are you
you're making it against the law and
putting you in prison cuz you commit a
crime against yourself in a free society
yeah so in this regard would you say
that you're fully libertarian cuz that
strikes me as a very libertarian view
you're saying we're saying do what you
want with your own body big whoop and do
what you want in life as long as you
don't harm anyone else you do what
you're free to do as long as you don't
harm another person or force them to do
something that's not free will for them
and as far as doing drugs hey read my
book for a hundred and sixty years
marijuana was the economic drive to the
entire United States of America did you
know that the British would take
marijuana in lieu of money I did not
know that yes because they needed it for
sales so they could colonize sales on
their ships rope all of that well
England's only the size of New York
State they couldn't have the room to
grow it so they made the colonists grow
it so that they could take it and use it
to further their Armada and their big
fleet I cover it all in the book first
so for a hundred and sixty years
marijuana was the economic engine that
drove the United States economy it
wasn't cotton until they invented the
cotton gin because marijuana was easier
to harvest yeah so what do you make of
the way that the feds and Obama
particularly has dealt with marijuana
cuz we know that in a lot of states now
it's medicinal illegal we've got a
couple of recreational legal I'm here in
California I have a license for it and I
I don't even smoke that often but I
thought if I'm gonna do it let me let me
go ahead and get the license but but
Obama and the feds have come in and they
closed medicinal dispensaries here you
know they're they're legal by the state
yeah well they want people to suffer
I'll tell you what made
he's so passionate on this I won't say
who because I respect people's privacy
of health but someone very close to me
marijuana has given me back my standard
of living Wow that's how powerful
because someone close to me developed an
epileptic seizure condition at a later
age and was seizing four times a week
and I was there I had to deal with this
seizure well the person was put on for
pharmaceutical drugs one at a time none
of them worked
they all had horrible side effects and
the seizures continued the person then
went to Colorado at the time where
medical was legal obtained it the
seizures immediately stopped now they
can the person could get it in Minnesota
because it's legal there now and for two
years now this person has not had a
seizure yeah and has completely weaned
off the pharmaceuticals completely so
it's the marijuana that is stopping the
epileptic seizure so to Barack Obama and
all our government how dare you make
people suffer because of your
shortsightedness and money because it
all comes back to money if they legalize
that they want Big Pharma to run it so
the big corporation will reap the
profits yeah they don't want it to where
poor people can grow it in their
backyard and be able to use it like when
I grew up in south Minneapolis every
summer my mom had a tomato patch we
didn't have a big yard burn in her city
yet she would have enough Tomatoes we
need fresh tomatoes all summer when they
came well you can do the same thing with
marijuana which means poor people don't
have to pay the system to get it and use
it there's the rub you know the irony
here of course is that all of these
prescription drugs that everybody's
taking all you have to do is watch any
of the commercials the commercials half
of the commercials telling you about the
side effects and then with the ultimate
irony it's usually marijuana that will
deal with those side effects so
what do we do so do we need basically
like Starbucks to come in and say we're
gonna start corporate izing marijuana no
no you don't want corporations taking
control well in terms of the legal party
okay look at it this way mm-hmm I don't
like Budweiser beer I would rather have
some micro brew or some brew that's
handmade Minnesota and doesn't sit in a
can on a shelf for months before I buy
it in the liquor store
well that's what you can do if you
eliminate the corporations from
marijuana then you'll have local it'll
be locally grown
it'll be local everything and that's why
in Ohio had failed because they had
picked out only two corporations that
would control the whole thing and the
marijuana smokers said [ __ ] that's
bullcrap we want it to where anybody can
grow it anyone can use it we want it
free like the plant is the plant grows
wild it was here before we got here and
ran off the Indians are the Native
Americans it was growing here so why
shouldn't it be able to grow wild and
you be able to harvest it without having
to pay the government to do it yeah I'm
with you so where do you stand on
legalization in general obviously you're
you're fully for legalizing marijuana
but that always then it hearkens the
next question well which is well does he
want to legalize cocaine and heroin and
everything else down the road yeah yes
here's why addiction is a medical
problem addictions of disease you can be
addicted to food all right tomorrow
morning let's imagine go to a
hypothetical let's say tomorrow morning
we could magically make Starbucks and
all caffeine coffee disappear what do
you think would happen to society
tomorrow morning if all these addicts
and I use the term addicts because they
are addicted and people need to
understand that if you have to have
coffee in the morning how dare you talk
about any other drug yeah I mean my head
my head
would literally explode in the morning I
can't hide luncheon see yeah I've had
two sips in my life and spit it out both
times to me it tastes like crap real and
so I don't drink coffee and I'm hyper
enough I don't need caffeine to get
going well the point I'm making is
everybody's addicted to something
obesity is a huge problem in our country
because the people are addicted to
eating now if they push themselves away
from the table and exercise you won't be
obese eat the right foods but do we
limit them No and like when they make it
legal it's not really legal even in
Colorado let me give you the example I
could drive to Colorado tomorrow right
and I could pull a semi in and I could
fill that semi up with tobacco could
night sure I could buy as many
cigarettes as I wanted and fill the semi
up I could drive to five liquor stores
and I could buy all their booze and fill
the semi up and nobody questioned me as
long as my credit card could pay for it
right
I could buy asthma yet marijuana a
Colorado resident can only buy one ounce
at a time and and if you're not from
Colorado you can only get a half an
ounce that ain't freedom yeah that means
it's still highly restricted so when
they talk about it's legal now no it
isn't really because they still limit
how much you can buy and why should the
government have any say-so whatsoever in
how you spend your money or if you want
to buy o45 outboard motor engines even
though you don't have a boat right you
know you want to do that you have the
freedom to do that well that's freedom
right meanwhile if you buy a pressure
cooker you're on a CIA watchlist or
something maybe yeah who knows yeah but
uh yeah and so it still isn't free
because it's so heavily restricted right
now and for what for what now do you
know who did it William Randolph Hearst
really the big guy with the newspapers
died in the thirties I drove that by his
that
hasil a couple months ago here's why he
owned 26 newspapers and marijuana and
hemp make better paper than wood he
owned thousands of acres of timberland
so he bought off the Republicans and
Democrats got them to make marijuana
federally illegal so it forced us to buy
his timber to make pay pan when you
start linking this stuff together it's
as he said earlier it's it's all down to
my money so so one more thing on
marijuana and then let's talk about
those Democrats and Republicans because
I have a feeling you have a couple
things to say about them as well it is
the most fascinating part about
marijuana that it's almost the reverse
of every other vice so for example with
booze if you drink
we know you build a resistance to it you
need more to drink if you do smoke crack
or snort coke or or drink coffee you
always need more marijuana I find and I
can firmly say this for me I used to
smoke a lot of marijuana now I could
maybe take one puff and I'm good for
hours and I do that maybe once a week so
it actually has like a built in
regulation system to it to actually
maybe but what you may be facing is this
it's more powerful today than what it
was years ago because of the strains and
the way they're able to grow it right
now that's not bad and let me explain
it's more healthy for you to be able to
take one puff than having to smoke the
whole joint sure see it's the same as
booze okay you can go out and buy a
liqueur that's maybe 20% or you can go
buy 151 rum well which one's gonna knock
you into tomorrow quicker 151 rum is
gone okay so if it's content well in the
case of marijuana if it's more potent
you're never gonna die from it the great
thing about marijuana you can't OD it
nobody's dad we're not gonna die from it
you can't you can die from overdosing
alcohol easily and all he said but
marijuana you can't and if it's more
powerful it means you smoke less you
might be able to have one joint if
you're a pal if
smoker who smokes all day one joint may
last you the whole day
yeah I'm take one in the morning one at
lunch one in the evening and one before
bed yeah when I got my license I went to
the dispensary and I was looking around
you know they got it in chocolate and in
you know in water and edible every every
which way and vaping and all that stuff
and I looked at the guy and I was like
do you have any weed in weed form
cuz I just wanted like old school weed
he looked at me like I was a little
weird but they eventually had it for me
nah he really did he was probably doing
that just ink but because this other
stuff might be more expensive again
follow the money it is utterly foolish
now we've spent since the war on drugs
started in 1972 by Nixon we've spent
close to a trillion dollars fighting it
putting Campbell in jail for doing
something recreationally for themselves
yeah and they're not harming anyone like
my fate my famous quote marijuana is to
rock and roll what beer is to baseball
imagine if you went to the ballgame and
you couldn't have a hotdog in a beer
well when you go to a rock concert in
the 60s and 70s when I grew up you
didn't have to have pot you just went
there peopled light a joint and send it
down the aisle people would not be happy
we would ever I wanted to be happy at
all yeah I'm yet they won't let you
smoke pot at a rock concert it's
ridiculous I went to a journey concert
in Orange County about a year ago and I
got narked while my friend and I were
puffing on a little a little joint I
mean can you believe that outdoor
concert by the way anyway should we move
to politics what do you think sure
alright let's let's shift for a little
bit we are in the midst of I think what
pretty much everybody is saying is the
craziest election at least in modern
times as a true outsider who made it
through the [ __ ] you got through the
system ran on the Reform Party ticket 99
became governor of Minnesota what do you
make of just before we get into the two
of them what do you just make of the
state of the system at the moment well
the system is broken and the system is
based upon the concept
to bribery where if you if you do
bribery in the private sector you go to
jail but in in our political system it's
the status quo you want an audience with
the candidate a democrat or republican
you better bring a check with you and
you better donate to their campaign
otherwise they they're not talking to
you and so it's a system of bribery and
the people who thrive in a system like
bribery have to be crooked to begin with
because if you're comfortable in a
bribery system then obviously you're
comfortable breaking laws and bending
rules and doing whatever it takes and so
that's really I think what's wrong as a
whole with our system today the
Democrats and Republicans have turned it
into a complete system of bribery yeah
when you look back on the fact that you
actually won as a third party candidate
in Minnesota does that does it almost
seem crazy to you now because it really
seems that at this point we've we've
gone so far backwards now that I don't
know that someone could do it anymore
well you can do it it could be done this
year if they'd allow Gary Johnson the
key is the debates mm-hmm
see the Dems and Republic they sing
Kumbaya with each other when it's time
to keep jill's dr. Stein and Gary
governor Johnson out of the debates
they're right in bed together on that
baby but but the point is they don't let
anyone else into the game as Ralph Nader
called that the two-party dictatorship
that's what you have in this country the
two-party dictatorship and they they
won't let anyone else in for fear that a
third entity like I was in Minnesota
will beat them and then oh my god what
do they do then right so only if they
get beat yeah
so speaking of getting beat I mean
Hillary beat Bernie but we know that the
d-ends own she cheated right so we know
the DNC was in on it so goddamn
it was fixed it was fixed Bernie wasn't
gonna win they got super della and the
minute I heard about super-delegates I
said what are these things that's the
facts so the fix was in Bernie didn't
have a chance
Hillary was gonna win and they fit in
who did they blame the Russians they
blame a blame a messenger not the
message if they hadn't wrote those
emails could anyone have hack them no
they wrote them and then how do they
know the Russians did it wasn't that
convenient let's blame the Russians are
the Russians that concerned over whether
Hillary or Trump win it doesn't matter
because it's the same Democrats and
Republicans are gonna be running the
thing anyway it sounds like the
beginning of a plot of a movie that you
should have been in in like 87 and then
you and Schwarzenegger go in there and
clean up [ __ ] maybe I don't know you
know when you look at it from that
aspect it is it's almost laughable like
a movie script but you know the whole
situation is they won't let anyone else
in the game for fear the rise of a third
party the third choice and this is the
year should happen because Trump and
Hillary's negatives are through the
ceiling yeah nobody likes either one of
them so deal why did they vote for a men
when you have other candidates why would
you vote for people you don't even like
yeah so do you think the real missed
opportunity here then was that instead
of Bernie just acquiescing and and sort
of being put down by by Hillary in the
DNC that he should be the third party
guy right now I get it with Gary Johnson
I did a video a couple weeks ago saying
we have to at least support this guy
until the debates because we need
another voice in there but do you think
Bernie actually missed his moment here
yeah and I knew what was gonna happen
because last summer Bernie came to
Minnesota and I went down there and I
actually went down there thinking I
would endorse him he gave me the
complete cold shoulder really oh he he
spoke to me in a hallway for one minute
and I all I got to ask him was the
important question I said senator
Sanders if you failed
feat Hillary Clinton for the Democratic
nomination will you keep the revolution
going by either running as an
independent or throw your support to an
independent he looked me right in the
eye and said nope I will endorse Hillary
right there I said he's a phony
because he's a Democrat and for him to
now mask himself as an independent is
phony Bernie Sanders is a Democrat
because once he said he'd endorse
Hillary Clinton no matter what that made
him a Democrat in my book he wouldn't
even go outside he wouldn't continue the
movement so all those people out there
that endorsed and got so behind Bernie
Sanders you got hoodwinked yeah and
those look like those people are not
excited to vote for Hillary so let's
talk about Hillary for a second I mean
from everything that you've said here
and everything that I know that you
believe about money and politics and a
corrupt system and politicians that lie
in a media that helps them lie it
strikes me that Hillary is the pinnacle
of that so is she I mean do you view her
as actually a real threat to the
underpinnings of what democracy is
supposed to be uh yeah because it's all
fixed or it proved or what the emails
that the whole democratic process was
fixed that they hand-picked her and it
didn't matter what went on she was going
to be the nomination yeah and and she
you know she takes a half a million
dollars to do a speech for Wall Street
that's not buying her right he can sit
and say that she's not influenced that
insults my intelligence right truly does
I'm pretty sure and the fact that she
here's the most important thing to me
the most important vote Hillary Clinton
ever took as a senator she admits she
blew it she voted for the Iraq war and
now she says that was a mistake so
sending our kids to war the most
important vote you could possibly take
as a politician hill
we got it wrong and admits to it now so
we're gonna put her thumb on the button
yeah and by the way whatever you think
of Benghazi specifically she was
Secretary of State for what we've done
in Libya and now all hell has broken
loose over there too so there's a
there's a series of bad decisions I'm
curious do you give any of the people
that voted for Iraq do you give any of
them a little bit of a leash because of
the way we now know that the information
that the intelligence community told
them things that weren't true you know
Colin Powell with uh with the rods you
don't buy any of that I was doing the
right wing radio talk show host once
when I was governor and the subject came
up and this guy said it's a difficult
decision not the hardest decision you
could make as an elected official to go
to war hmm I looked at him and said
you're wrong it's an easy decision
and he jumped all over me how can you
say it's an easy decision to go to war
when he was done I told him why and I'll
tell you why going to war is an easy
decision here's why a war is justified
if you're willing to send your kids to
fight it hmm if you ain't willing to
send your kids how do you send someone
else's and I can unequivocally tell you
I would not have sent my kids to Iraq
yeah and that's as simple as it gets
it's justified if you're willing to send
your children to fight it and if you're
not willing to do that how do you send
someone else's kids to do it sure and
and we always have money to do it even
though we somehow don't have money to
fix our infrastructure and our roads and
all that so all right let's let's put
Hilary aside now and let's move to Trump
I'm gonna partly put some put some words
in your mouth to preface this I have a
feeling that you kinda like Trump that
just on the outsider part of it the
wrestling part of it be the breaking the
system getting through the [ __ ]
saying things off the top of your head
for that portion of it I'm gonna say
that you're a pro Trump absolutely yeah
and I like what he's done I like he's
fractured the Republican Party just as I
liked it when Bernie fractured the
Democrats
remember something Pat Buchanan and the
Republicans destroyed the Reform Party
when they came in a 98 or 2000 Pat
Buchanan brought his minions in and they
had a mistake in the Reform Party you
could become a same-day delegate so he
brought in all his people got the
nomination took 30 million of our
dollars and never even ran guest who
watched all that Donald Trump because
Donald Trump came and supported me and
Anna soda in 98 Donald ain't a
Republican he's an independent right he
just joined the Republicans like Bernie
joined the Democrats well Trump watched
Pat Buchanan and destroy the Reform
Party he essentially now did the same
thing to them right back in their face
he came in and destroyed their party of
what it used to be so I cheer him for
that now I've known Donald for 25 years
I consider him a friend but will I
support him no because we've differ
completely on the Middle East
I'm anti-war get out of there they're
gonna go to war
no matter which one of these two people
you elect four years from now we're
still gonna be at war but having said
that I also differ with Donald on
immigration I live in Mexico half the
year I love Mexicans they're wonderful
people I don't want to live in East
Berlin we're gonna put a wall up excuse
me
Ronald Reagan is the is the icon of the
modern day Republican right I don't
supposed to be well I don't think Ronald
Reagan could even be a Republican today
but that aside it seems to me his iconic
quote was mr. Gorbachev tear down this
wall what is he thinking today knowing
the United States is possibly gonna
build a wall and that we're gonna become
East Berlin so so putting the wall
here's I read all wait here's your
trade-off if we're gonna then we should
take down the Statue of Liberty there's
a statue
liberté says send us your poor send us
your downtrodden and all that well we
obviously don't want them so let's take
down the Statue of Liberty it's outdated
today right I mean isn't that the whole
point of immigration usually countries
don't send you there their brightest and
their and their best but it's the people
that need help and that's why most of
our ancestors came here it'll who come
here for to make their way to go after
the American dream
you can come yours in the immigrant and
end up a millionaire the opportunities
there yeah so so I'm with you on on all
of that and and I've said many times I
don't know if the wall is sensible or
financially sound or any of that stuff
wait I'll tell you how sensible it is
yeah you build a 30-foot wall and I'll
find somebody with a 31 foot ladder so
it's good for the ladder people to know
no it does work though you want to know
how I know it works because centuries
ago they built the Great Wall of China
and there ain't one Mexican that I know
of that no that is a good point that's I
can't think of John I would have to go
by I would have to google that after and
find out what's what so I know a certain
amount of people are gonna hear you and
they're gonna say wait a minute Ventura
wants open borders and blah blah blah
what would you say about cuz you also
don't trust the government so it puts
your position in an interesting spot
because I would I'm with you but then it
comes to alright well how do we vet
people properly and I don't trust that
the government will do it properly or
knows how to do it properly or even can
do it properly
well government's about compromising so
I'll give you my compromise okay yeah
you have to bring home and close our
hundred and seventy eight military bases
throughout the world and bring our kids
home and then use our military to
protect our border I heard an interview
where a BBC guy was grilling President
Putin of Russia Vladimir Putin and he
was really getting on him about Russia's
aggression and Putin very calmly said to
him well let's really talk about this
openly Russia has two military bases
outside of the country of Russia the
United States I believe has something
like a hundred and seventy eight who's
the aggressor yeah I mean Bill Maher
says it all the time it's like we still
have forty thousand troops are saying
stationed in Germany the war is over the
war is over the point is who's the
aggressor yeah we accused Russia of
being aggressive I would shine the
mirror on us and say were the aggressors
hundred and seventy eight bases
throughout the world for what bring them
home close him down
so if enough let the rest of the country
defend themselves yeah
so if enough people heard that message
how do you actually do it cuz I think a
lot of people hear the spirit of what
you're saying and say yeah it doesn't
make sense to do all this stuff but how
do you actually untie all of this stuff
well Ron Paul I remember when
Congressman Paul was opposed to the Iraq
war and they said well we're already in
there how can we get out now
and I thought Congressman Paul had the
greatest dancer in the world
he said we marched in all we have to do
is turn around and march out yeah but do
we bear some responsibility then because
although I obviously well well like for
example so when we went into Iraq
originally by the time Obama had us pull
out it was doing better they were having
free elections and all that then we we
left in a haste and now it's basically a
war zone again so it's like we're damned
if we do it we're damned if we don't we
got in and then we left in a messy way
and now it's worse okay Jesse's gonna
give you the lesson on the Middle East
now Freyja brother III spoke once and I
had a woman come up to me after Muslim
and as Bill Maher said she was decked
out in the beekeeper suit right but her
face wasn't covered but she had up all
the Muslim attire young woman she walked
up to me when I was done speaking and
she said to me this she said you
understand the Middle East why doesn't
anyone else here and now I'm gonna
explain it to you what you have in the
Middle East today is blowback it is
blowback from Cologne
Ania lism you have to go way back to
them when Europe Colonia lies the whole
world and went through that when they
got to the Middle East they made the
countries to benefit them the Europeans
they didn't make the countries to
benefit the people who live there you
had three warring factions there the
Shiites the Kurds and the Sunnis rather
than giving them all their own country
they put all three of them in every
country yeah
so the wars continued on and on inside
the borders of the countries so the only
way the countries could be governed was
by a dictator the minute then the United
States comes along and decides we're
gonna remove the dictators and give them
democracy people who wouldn't know
democracy if it bit him on the ass we
take out the dictators and what do you
have now total chaos and total
disruption of the entire region and when
will the United States look in the
mirror and take ownership for what's
gone on over there but we don't bear the
ownership do we Isis exists because of
what we did we went into Iraq and you
got Bush and Cheney who never went to
war running the OP right well anybody
with any knowledge will tell you you
don't dis man the military like we did
we put him in unemployment right Bremer
went over there and kicked them out the
door
well they then went up and formed and
became Isis if you invade someone you
keep the military intact because it's a
strange thing with military military
will follow who's ever in charge that
way you've got the whole Iraqi army is
still on the payroll they can feed their
families they're gonna do what you want
them to do instead George Bush and Dick
Cheney and
Remer cut him loose yeah now we won't
take responsibility we created Isis look
if you want one other example of that
it's that we have a military
dictatorship now after they tried
democracy in Egypt and it's one of the
only stable places governor I know you
have to go so real quick who is winning
this election I want the official
prediction right now well I figure
Hillary probably because it's fixed you
know well her nomination was fixed why
wouldn't you believe the rest of the
elections gonna be fixed the same way we
shall see all right well it's always a
pleasure talking to your governor I know
you got a long game press ahead of you
so I want to thank Governor Jesse
Ventura for joining me on the show this
week and you guys can check out his new
book the marijuana manifesto Jesse
Ventura is marijuana manifesto in the
link that is right down below thanks
again governor
[Music]
you
[Music]